If our critical region is only up here, above the mean. Then, any sample mean
in this yellow, or orange, area will be considered likely. However, with a z
score of negative 2.59, would we necessarily consider that likely? So instead,
let's split the critical region in 2. Again, let's focus on just the alpha
level of 0.05 for now. If we split 0.05 in 2, then that means 2.5% is on this
side. I drew this 2.5% disproportionately larger just so you can see. But let's
just pretend that this area in blue is 2.5%. And that also means that 2.5% is
on this side. So in total they make 5%. So this is for an alpha level of 0.05.
So this means we have different z critical values. What is this z critical
value that should go here? Just write it as a positive value.